il ya une semaine dans le monde sur
france 24 ont fait le tour d une
internationale de la semaine avec nos
éditorialistes avec au sommaire ce soir
la guerre en ukraine bien sûr toujours
avec des batailles très dur dans le
donbass notamment à severodonetsk et
l'impact l'impact de ce conflit sur les
exportations de blé ukrainien qui font
craindre une crise alimentaire notamment
dans les pays d'afrique le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov est allé
en turquie rencontrer son homologue pour
discuter de la mise en place de
corridors sécurisés la russie exerce un
blocus vous le savez autour des ports
d'ukrainiens de la mer noire
le roi des belges qui a exprimé ses plus
profonds regrets pour les blessures
infligées à la rdc pendant la période
coloniale un discours marquant alors que
le roi philippe est en visite en rdc
pendant six jours peut-être un nouveau
départ dans les relations entre la
belgique et la république démocratique
du congo
on va évoquer également cette enquête
enquête parlementaire qui placent donald
trump au centre d'une tentative de coup
d'état dans l'assaut du capitole du 6
janvier 2021 les premières auditions
sont accablantes pour l'ancien président
américain l'audition est retransmise
d'ailleurs en direct sur de nombreuses
chaînes d'information en continu mais
boudée par fox news
enfin boris johnson johnson qui reste à
son poste mais il a connu vous le savez
une fronde au sein de son propre parti
le premier ministre britannique a
survécu au vote de défiance mais il en
sort affaibli une fausse victoire titre
le quotidien conservateur le telegraph
alors pour le premier ministre
britannique est ce le début de la fin on
posera bien sûr la question à
d'éditorialistes qui m'accompagne ce
soir alexandra elle schwarz broad
bonsoir directrice adjointe de la
rédaction de libération bienvenue dans
la semaine dans le monde 4 qui est avec
nous président de cartooning for peace
bonsoir cac les chars wehrli
éditorialistes france europe pour le
quotidien suisse blick cap bienvenu
également avoue richard patricia
patricia allemonière grand reporter
merci d'être avec nous ce soir vous
pouvez tous participé à l'émission en
posant vos questions sur les réseaux
sociaux hashtag débat f24 on va démarrer
avec la guerre en ukraine alexandra
hachoir brut de 100 soldats ukrainien
sont tués chaque jour c'est en tout cas
ce que dit maintenant aux élèves ce qui
s'est combats font toujours rage à ses
vers audio n'y est ce que kiev cible
maintenant des positions à kherson
personnes donc qui est une région dont
quasiment totalement sous contrôle russe
on peut dire que la guerre fait rage
c'est toujours effectivement l'est de
l'ukraine et le sud qui sont ciblés par
les russes oui c'est là dessus que les
russes se sont repliés depuis qu'ils ont
bien vu qu'il ne pouvait pas prendre qui
a fait le reste de de l'ukraine donc ils
se sont repliés sur ces régions qu'ils
sont en train de pilonner mais vraiment
de façon massive en train en détruisant
tout ce qui ce qui peut être détruit et
c'est vrai qu'on voit bien que les
ukrainiens commencent à tirer la langue
les ukrainiens qui ceux qui ont commencé
voilà on comme on le voit depuis le 24
février qui se bat avec avec une énergie
et une foi en leurs capacités à bouter
les russes hors d'ukraine incroyable et
là là on voit comment ça tirait la
langue il commence à être à court de
d'armes de munitions d'où les appels à
l'aide de limerzel en ski à l'adresse
des pays occidentaux le problème c'est
qu'on a l'impression que les pays
occidentaux sont beaucoup moins allants
que qu'il ne l'était au tout début de la
guerre quand il livré des armes de façon
massive quand ils assuraient les
ukrainiens de l'heure de leur soutien
total là on sent presque une habitude
une chance de fatigue s de fatigue
l'impression que ça va être une guerre
d'usure et donc qu'il faut il faut y
aller mollo l'impression tout toujours
l'impression que ce n'est pas leur
guerre c'est à dire qu'on sent bien que
les occidentaux ne veulent pas mettre le
petit doigt dans cette guerre ne veulent
pas si les belligérants n'ont surtout qu
belligérantes patricia surtout la france
l'allemagne et l'italie un peu moi qui
veulent pas qu'ils ont des cette
prudence en tout cas ne pas ne pas
vouloir être belligérants je crois que
quand on se déplace dans la partie est
de l'europe on est beaucoup plus allants
et quand on est en grande bretagne ou le
royaume uni on est aussi beaucoup plus
allants ça ne veut pas dire qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'armes qui sont livrés
par ces pays il faut savoir que le seul
pays qui livre m des armes massivement
ses les états unis et justement les les
ukrainiens ou un besoin désespéré de ces
fameux lance-roquettes qui tire à plus
de 80 km et qui pose problème parce que
elles pourraient être tirés avec
d'autres missiles à 300 et là ça
pourrait effectivement tombé sur le
territoire donc donc c'est un peu la
ligne rouge c'est un peu la ligne rouge
effectivement est ce que richard
severodonetsk est ce que c'est un peu le
nouveau marioupol en tout cas c'est
l'une des batailles les plus difficiles
c'est ce qu'elle a dit zelensky ce qui
est certain c'est que les ukrainiens
vont avoir besoin d'une victoire ils
vont avoir besoin d'une victoire d'abord
pour la population ukrainienne pour
convaincre que cette résistance cette
contre offensive contre l'armée russe
elle peut marcher parce que là il ya une
question de morale quand on parle de
guerre d'usure c'est le moral de la
population qui est en jeu et quand on
voit la manière dont vladimir poutine
fait combattre ses troupes c'est
clairement pour casser le moral de la
population ukrainienne en aplatissant
des villes entières donc ils vont avoir
besoin d'un succès militaires qui nous
peut évidemment être obtenue qu'avec le
gendarme le genre d'armement dont
patricia parler et puis il faut aussi
une victoire pour convaincre les
occidentaux et notamment les européens
que ça vaut le coup de les aider donc là
il y à une phase cruciale moi ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup
c'est l'été qui va venir parce que quand
l'été va venir naturellement on sait que
dans les pays d'europe occidentale
l'attention va se relâcher et ça peut
être le moment vladimir poutine va
repartir encore plus pour une troisième
vague d'assaut pour profiter de cette
période estivale là il ya un grand
danger d'où l'urgence du frisson
d'argenterie présence d'armes qu'ils
demandent en tout cas elle demande même
des armes lourdes un volume limité lasky
l'impact en tout cas tu cette guerre sur
les exportations de blé ukrainien font
craindre une crise alimentaire notamment
dans les pays d'afrique sergueï lavrov
est allé en turquie rencontrer son
homologue mevlüt cavusoglu pour
justement discuter de la mise en place
de corridors sécurisés destinés à
transporter les céréales la russie vous
le savez exerce un blocus autour des
ports d'ukrainiens de la mer noire on va
écouter sergueï lavrov le chef de
diplomatie russe
vous les ukrainiens vous êtes toujours
préoccupé par ce que vous pouvez voler
et vous pensez que c'est comme ça que
tout le monde pense nous avons expliqué
aujourd'hui que les céréales peuvent
être exportées librement vers leur
destination il n'y a aucun obstacle de
la part de la russie une seule chose est
nécessaire c'est l'ordre de monsieur
zelensky s'il peut encore décider quoi
que ce soit d'autoriser les navires
étrangers et même ukrainien à entrer
dans la mer noire
dans une réaction à ce que dit anthony
blinken le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mais ils évoquent un chantage
alimentaire de moscou objectivement on
ne voit pas bien pourquoi les russes les
russes se comporteraient autrement ils
peuvent très bien au contraire ils
doivent être enchanté conviennent les
supplier qu'on les suppliques comme ça
de de desserrer l'étau sur la mer noire
c'est ils font ils
ont beau jeu de dire on nous met des
sanctions insupportables nous on utilise
normalement milices larmes alimentaire
et c'est tout simplement ce qu'ils sont
en train de faire il n'y a aucune raison
qu'il dessert cet étau dans les semaines
qui viennent et ça va et c'est vrai que
ça va être on va vers un problème
dramatique dramatique parce que en effet
comme vous l'avez dit l'afrique
l'afrique reçoit ses céréales quasiment
exclusivement de l'ukraine et du coup ça
va conduire et on voit déjà ça va
conduire à des à des espèces de guerre
civile des guerres de la fin des guerres
du pain comme on ne pensait pas en
connaître à nouveau
à notre époque et ça va être un vrai
doudou le branle bas de combat
diplomatique pour essayer de faire
pression las vegas en turc mais là mais
voilà mais on ne voit pas bien pourquoi
les russes céderait sur ce point il
renoncerait hills et renoncerait
patricia c'est vrai que effectivement
quelle contrepartie pour la levée du
blocus en fait eux disent que c'est la
faute des ukrainiens on l'a entendu
sergueï lavrov ans alors que ce sont les
navires russes qui sont dans la mer
noire qui empêche effectivement les
exportations du blé ukrainien je crois
qu'il ya des choses c'est de bonne
guerre de toute façon leur attitude ils
n'ont pas de raison de deux se
présentent autrement d'autant que
vis-à-vis de l'afrique ils ont beau jeu
en plus n'oublions pas que bon nombre de
pays africains que les soutiennent ne
vote pas les résolution qui condamne la
russie donc ils ont tout à fait bon
jouer enfin vis-à-vis des africains du
drame et nous on est prêts on me met
malien des mines est tellement on est on
est gentil on peut même des mines et les
ports craignent alors les ukrainiens
évidemment qu est ce qu ils disent avoir
accordé si vous des mines et nos ports
nous on veut des armes occidentales pour
défendre nos comparses que des mines et
nos ports ça veut dire que la l'armée
russe peut très bien après rentrée et
c'est donc les ukrainiens n'ont pas
répondu par la négative ils ont dit ok
si vous les occidentaux où on nous
fournit des armes pour défendre nos
comptes et auquel si les navires de
l'otan escorte aussi nos convois donc là
les russes effectivement ils se battent
encore donc ça n'aboutit pas ça
n'aboutit pas et les russes demandent en
plus sa levée des sanctions originel
évidemment totalement refusé côté avoué
salle richart un mot peut-être sur
l'attitude et les mots employés par
sergueï lavrov quand on pense que ce
ministre a longtemps été considéré comme
un grand diplomate
vous avez vu les mots qu'ils utilisent
l'ironie la manière dont il parle c'est
juste odieux ses voeux ça prouve le
visage actuel du régime de vladimir
poutine juste juste parce qu'on parle
d'alimentation et la manière dont ils
s'expriment et juste absolument indigne
ensuite un élément là par contre moi je
dis faire un petit peu parce que il ya
heureusement des informations positives
sur le plan mondial pour ce qui concerne
la production agricole la récolte des
céréales cette année va être très bonne
dans le monde un grand pays producteurs
comme l'australie va brio riz avoir une
très bonne récolte il y en a d'autres
dans le monde donc il y a versification
des approvisionnements qui va être
possible ça c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle il va falloir s'y atteler très
vite et c'est en cours est par ailleurs
parmi les pays africains qui ont besoin
de d'alimentation de céréales il y en a
rappelons le qui sont en situation
extrêmement difficile parce qu'en
général ils ne peuvent importer que sous
forme d' aide mais il y en a qui peuvent
payer je rappelle qu'un pays comme
l'algérie qui consomment beaucoup de
céréales à profite quand même de la
hausse du prix l'énergie grâce au gaz et
il peut donc payer une facture plus
élevée en tout cas c'est effectivement
cette manière de contourner ce blocus
face n'y aura pas véritablement durera
pas de levée de ce blocus par les russes
on va écouter macky sall macky sall
métal est d'ailleurs plaidé à sotchi la
cause de l'union africaine il demande de
libérer les stocks de céréales macky
sall président sénégalais qui est
d'ailleurs à paris où la vue est mesnel
macro pour à nouveau évoquer cette
question des céréales on les écoute
c'est un communiqué avec le président de
l'as de la commission de l'union
africaine dans sa fac communiqué
conjoint pauvre con à l'intervention et
exiger le respect la seconde
cela ne vaut pas dupe je dois pas parler
à la russie lorsque je considère que le
marché est bloqué parce que d'une part
un des grands fournisseurs qu'ils
n'arrivent plus à exporter mon devoir
est le doigt des africains de
sensibiliser un peu dans pour dean sur
ce fait de demander d'agir de concert
avec les marchands génie pour que cette
contrainte soit levée ex la chasse c'est
une demande de mon données sont unies
d'intervenir emmanuel macron aussi
serait dans cette optique diplomatique
d'utiliser les nations unies pour créer
ces fameux corridor alors il ya eu deux
tentatives déjà un des nations unies
pour l'instant ça n'aboutit par mail
guti pas est-ce qu'on il ya un autre
élément aussi cesser les vols de
céréales par la russie la russie
profitent de la situation pour voler des
céréales et les revendre deux façons de
façon illégale à des pays peu regardants
par exemple on sait qui est un bateau
qui a mené des céréales volé à l'ukraine
en syrie ans et récemment et en
s'abonnant lettre de libération
d'ailleurs l'intégration de dit notre
problème mais c'est le même problème en
fait parce que les pays américains vont
se retrouver avec du blé volé aux
ukrainiens a effectivement peut-être
négocié à plus bas prix donc s il
accepte de l'acheter est ce qu'ils se
rendent complices c'est ça aussi la
question par la hausse de la fin c'est
une arme terrible je les trouve et la
russie anciennement union soviétique a
utilisé déjà cette fameuse arme de la
fin on se souvient des millions de morts
l'ukrainien et et même avant et même
souvenez-vous hitler voulu utiliser
aussi larmes de la fin contre l'ukraine
donc dans ce pays là se faire voler ses
céréales pour les faire vendre en
loucedé à des pays ça ça leur parle dans
leur chair parce que leur grand-père est
leur arrière-grand-père ans sont morts
de donc ils savent très bien ce que ça
veut dire pour l'afrique mourir de faim
parce qu'on peut pas avoir accès ou
céréales et donc c'est une résonance que
pour nous on n'envisage même pas ici et
macky sall en même temps l espoir
évidemment qu'avec cette position de non
alignés ils vont pouvoir trouver une
solution diplomatique peut-être à l'aide
des nations unies ou de l'union
africaine pour que ces corridors puisse
peut-être existé un jour richard si vous
êtes un pays comme le sénégal et en plus
cela il s'est exprimé au nom de l'union
africaine très franchement il n'y a rien
à redire à sa déclaration qui lie
discuter avec vladimir poutine
c'est assez logique donc moi je pense
que les pays africains il est normal
qu'ils rappellent la communauté
internationale à l'ordre sur le plan
alimentaire on connaît leur dépendance
envers l'aide alimentaire c'est évident
mais encore une fois regardons de
manière plus globale il y à cette année
ça sera peut-être pas vrai dans quelques
mois il y à cette année la possibilité
de diversifier les approvisionnements y
compris aux états unis où la récolte a
semblé qu'il est très bonne et c'est ça
qui doit se mettre en place d'urgence le
roi des belges à vos pardon doit passer
au mode et s'empare boukakes alors les
dessinateurs
alors je me suis concentré sur la partie
alimentaire de ce sujet pour aujourd'hui
et je vous propose trois dessins tous
les trois c'est simple mais je trouve
assez fort il se passe tous autour du
blé qui servira de symbole pour toutes
les céréales dans ses dessins le premier
d'oussama ajaj un dessinateur de
jordanie voyez c'est très simple il
fallait y penser à partie quand tout
qu'est ce qui nous empêche d'accéder à
un champ de blé quand on est un oiseau
normalement évidemment un épouvantail
avantage je le rappelle qui est basée
sur le mot épouvante ce qui convient si
bien je trouve à ce bladimir poutine un
dessin très jolie d'osama ajaj ensuite
nicolas vadot le dessinateur belge pour
l'écho j'ai bien aimé l'allusion à la
mort menace sur les récoltes de blé en
ukraine l'occupant a confisqué toutes
les faucheuses évidemment vous aurez
compris l'allusion vous la voyez
d'ailleurs cette faucheuse perché sur le
tank russe qui est dans le fond dessins
aux couleurs du drapeau ukrainien
évidemment dessin très complet de
nicolas vadot et enfin ce troisième
dessins de ali jeanne sheedy phare
dessinateur iranien qui lui fait
allusion peut-être à ce qui pourrait se
produire si jamais on n'arrivait pas à
alimenter tous les pays bientôt la
prochaine vague les réfugiés alimentaire
je trouve le dessin assez beau et que
ces colonnes de fourmi qui rappelle
effectivement c'est que qu'on a vu de
migrants essayant de traverser les
frontières pour aller vers un un paysage
meilleur et donc avec ce petit sac de
blé qui symbolise l'objectif à atteindre
très beau dessin de ali hadji j'aime
sidi fars voilà pour moi et on va passer
à la visite du roi des belges en rdc le
roi des belges qui est exprimé son plus
profond regret pour les blessures
infligées à la rdc pendant la période
coloniale il espère marquer un nouveau
départ dans les relations entre la
belgique et la rdc on va écouter un
extrait de son discours c'était mercredi
à kinshasa
[Musique]
existent et peuvent à ce propos mairie
et elle
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je fais
m
donc les échos
alors les regrets sont ils suffisants
alexandra schwartzbrod pour amorcer une
réconciliation certains auraient voulu
des excuses objectivement quand on pense
à ce qu'a été la vie dans ce pays sous
la colonisation belge alors je dis pas
que les autres les autres pays coloniaux
se sont mieux comportés mais quand on
regarde ce qui s'est passé par exemple
sous léopold deux camps les ouvriers
étaient systématiquement amputé en la
récolte n'étaient pas assez bonnes
et ça c'est voilà ça c'était c'était le
quotidien quand on pense à toutes les
compromissions toutes les toutes les
horreurs c'est vrai que les regrets ça
paraît extrêmement léger c'est très très
léger et le jeu jouent alors vous me
direz c'est un début c'est mieux que
rien
mais il faut que ce soit un début si
c'est si c'est une fin ce n'est pas
suffisant si c'est un début
il ya encore beaucoup de boulot à faire
patrice et or ce qui a été bien
accueilli le roi des belges en tout cas
la population à kinshasa globalement
évidemment mais c'est drôle vous faites
allusion à léopold ii c'est une période
absolument abominable pour ce pic parce
que en crawl au début c'était le le
concours falloir 10 et appartenait
c'était c'était diop le jardin privé
jardin privé
faisait ce qu'il en voulait avant que ce
soit finalement à reconstituer considère
pas des sens uniques en mettant sous
domination belge mais le rapport c'est
très étonnant le rapport des dés de ce
pays avec la belgique n'est pas du tout
un rapport ne nous pouvons avoir avec
certaines de nos anciennes colonies les
dirigeants de ce pays aussi bien kabila
père kabila fils que le dirigeants
actuels sont plutôt non non qu'un apport
d'hostilité ne demande pas de la
repentance ne demande rien disent même
qu'ils sentent presque chez eux en
belgique c'est le second congo donc il
ya un rapport relativement apaisée entre
les dirigeants des deux pays quand on
pense à tout ce qui se passe avec
l'algérie ou ce qui se passe avec le
mali où ce qui se passe avec et ce qui
peut se passer avec d'autres pays ce qui
s'est passé un moment donné en côte
d'ivoire on est très loin la relation
beaucoup plus apaisé et ses treize le
roi philippe à marca tournant alors le
roi philippe effectivement marque un
tournant il entame un processus mais il
n'y a pas la même pression et le même
rapport de conflits qu'on peut avoir en
france avec nos anciennes colonies je
crois que c'est très important saint cyr
pour comprendre cette lenteur à laquelle
vous faites allusion mais une chose que
vous avez rappelé toutes les deux c'est
que le congo était au départ la
propriété du roi léopold ii autrement
dit
la responsabilité de la famille de
philippe l'actuel roi des belges est
directement mis en cause par la
colonisation qui a eu au congo et donc
on peut comprendre que ce soit espérons
le une première étape tout de même un
point bas presque eu la responsabilité
de la belgique est vraiment avancé
lorsqu'il s'agit de présenter des
regrets c'est un peu toute la question
et non une peut-être un point quand même
c'est que je trouve que la manière dont
il s'est exprimé
on a vu c'est assez sobre et moi ce que
je constate c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
polémique en belgique et en belgique
belgique en belgique c'est à dire que là
il ya une grande différence avec la
france vous vous souvenez de la
déclaration du maquereau colonisation
une contre l'humanité en algérie le
débat en france avait été énorme sur le
thème il n'aurait jamais dû dire ça et
c'est là une commission j'ai
l'impression que la belgique est
beaucoup plus prête même au pardon le
peuple belge que ne le sont les français
sur ce sujet et peut-être des des
réparations en tout cas c'est le fantôme
de patrice lumumba qui plane sur ce
voyage c'est intéressant d'y revenir
avec la fameuse dans ne doit être
restitué donc là dedans qui est la seule
la seule chose qui reste du corps de
patrice lumumba qui avait été dit soyez
dignes et dissous dans l'acide rasé et
donc qui va être restituée en effet à
kinshasa et est en effet cessé c'est
vraiment le fantôme qui qui reste
l'homme le premier premier ministre et
c'est important et les mythiques en plus
voilé orero relais l'état de vertus
qu'il n'avait probablement dont on a
appris cette semaine je crois suite à
des documents déclassifiés que
eisenhower le président américain avait
clairement donné l'ordre de l'assassiner
donc c'était un assassinat il a été
torturé enfin bon est-ce qu'il faut
revisiter justement revoir le passé
tirer les leçons du passé pour pouvoir
avoir une nouvelle relation apaisée
réconciliée entre ces deux pays c'est
important moi je pense comme la france
peut essayer de le faire aussi avec
l'algérie moi je pense c'est important
d'avoir des relations décomplexées c'est
à dire que et apaisée et de regarder
effectivement l'histoire sans sens sans
rose s'en viennent c'est l'histoire de
nos de nos ancêtres en quelque sorte
c'est pas l'histoire des hommes présents
alors les hommes présents peuvent avoir
un regard sur cette histoire là et donc
je crois que la jeune génération en tout
cas ils prêtent même en france et les
débats qui sont français qui sont assez
assez sain je veux dire pas violent mais
voyez dans deux tendus et bien sont
aussi très billets à noter que la
décolonisation et que l'algérie c'est
très proche et non seulement elle y est
prête mais le réclame swizz le jeune
général soit il en a tenu en tout cas
une grande partie a tourné en tout cas
la page des conflits des rigueurs des
oui il reste ça reste une poche de 2,2
de souffrance de culpabilité de nom de
l'absence de dialogue
d'incompréhension vaille c'est ça la
france est entre la france et l'algérie
essentiellement willis a une envie de
nous et non parce que moi je voi et vos
enfants ils sentent pas du tout coupable
enfin je veux dire eux ils aimeraient
comprendre il aimerait savoir ils
aimeraient apprendre au contraire et
parce qu'ils ne savent pas grand chose
une différence tout de même énorme et
qui explique sans doute l'attitude des
mails chez que le congo n'a jamais été
la belgique alors que l'algérie a été la
france est donc bien évidemment le
contexte historique le lien n'a rien à
voir et d'ailleurs à l'époque où se
produisent et ces choses abominables à
l'époque de léopold 2 le congo était
gérée par des concessions donc léopold
ii on avait la propriété milan déléguer
l'exploitation à des concessions
forestières qui se comporter de cette
manière mais là la france en afrique il
ya une hostilité montrent beaucoup au
mali dans plein de pays
ça france 24
alors visiter ce qu'elle a inspiré les
oui oui à liart dessinateur un peu
partout c'est un sujet qui était aussi
suivi par nos membres on va commencer
avec ce dessin de rawdon for peace les
membres de cartooning for peace
absolument des saints row dont le roi
philippe de belgique en visite en rdc
faites comme chez vous il à son
interlocuteur bon c'est simple mais
c'est terrible hystérique daf c'était
fini que c'est une gifle ce dessin
bavoirs au dos ce dessin maintenant de
damien glez dessinateur du burkina faso
vont m'apporter des masques d'initiation
mokanda se polit au congo à non trop tôt
c'est du chocolat belge on cultive le
cacao en belgique pour le dessin est un
peu absurde en une pièce de boulevard
mais je le trouve assez drôle et
toujours ce talent incroyable de dagne
anglais pour les caricatures c'est un
vraiment un des plus doués que je
connaisse et enfin ce dessin assez
amusant de berthet vanco sur les
reliques de lumumba qui retourne en
afrique tenez c'est la dent qu'il avait
contre nous et oui c'est très simple
elle joue avec l'expression mais c'est
assez bien trouvée puisque je rappelle
le monde a été aussi une grande figure
de la pendant ce niveau là est
d'ailleurs une historienne sur ce
plateau même disait qu'il fallait relire
le discours de lumumba et que d'ailleurs
les belges devraient relire le discours
de lumumba pour rentrer dans ce rapport
avec la rdc
aux etats unis c'est l'assaut du
capitole qui a été la culmination d'une
tentative de coup d'état un an et demi
après les événements du 6 janvier 2021
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
a placé donald trump au centre d'un
complot visant à le maintenir au pouvoir
ce groupe d'élus sept démocrates et de
républicains a entendu plus de 1000
témoins et peluches et 140 mille
documents pour faire la lumière sur les
faits et gestes précis de donald trump
l'audition est retransmise en direct sur
les chaînes d'info sauf fox news la
chaîne conservatrice qui a refusé en
fait de les transmettre en direct la
commission a d'ailleurs reçu le
témoignage d'une policière caroline
edwards la première membres des forces
de l'ordre à avoir été blessé par les
émeutiers on va l'écouter et puis on va
également écouter un extrait de ce qu'a
pu dire liste chesnais l'une des rares
élus républicaine qui siège au sein de
ses collections
il y avait des officiers au sol vous
savez il saignait il vomissait
j'ai vu des amis avec du sang sur le
visage
je bossais dans le sens des gens
j'attrapais les gens pendant qu'ils
tombent s
c'était un carnage
c'était le 15
je me suis entraîné pour arrêter des
gens pour gérer une foule axe mais je ne
me suis pas entraîné pour le combat
ceux qui ont envahi notre capitole et
combattu les forces de l'ordre pendant
des heures était motivé par ce que le
président entre eux que leur avait dit
que l'élection avait été volée et qu'il
était le président légitime
le président trump a convoqué et
rassemblé la foule et il a allumé la
flamme de cette attaque
fdc vitalement accablant pour donald
trump à la limite à la limite moi c'est
pas ça qui me fait le plus peur et qui
me surprend le plus tous ceux qui ont
suivi la présidence trump qui ont suivi
en direct devant devant sa télé le ce
qui se passait là bas à la limite c'est
presque enfin voilà on retrouve cette
violence ce qui me fait le plus peur ce
qui me surprend le plus c'est que les
américains malgré tout ce qui est en
train d'être dit alors les américains il
est citoyen américain malgré tout si ça
se trouve vont continuer à soutenir
trump voire même le réélire à ce qu'est
ce qui est pire que tout enfin pire que
tout il est républicain comment les
républicains peuvent ils continuer à
soutenir cet homme quand quand ils
entendent quand ils voient des
témoignages pareil quand ils entendent
par exemple que donald trump a même
aurait même n'aurait pas dédaigné voir
mike pence pendu au bout d'une horde
c'est ça il a encouragé donc c'est ce
que montre la reddition de mériter a dit
qu'il méritait au moment où ses
partisans disent hey you rafting pence
en fin de rependre peines et lui les
républicains continuent continuer à
soutenir donald trump et si ça se trouve
dans la trame sera réélu la prochaine à
la prochaine élection et les cinq années
d'existence en fait ils disent que cette
commission une commission politique que
justement elle n'est pas fiable mais
pour revenir justement sur ce que dit
donc vous disiez que sur mike pence au
moment où lui s'apprêtaient à certifier
le vote donald trump a répondu à ses
partisans qu'il fallait effectivement
qu'ils avaient raison de dire qu'il
fallait le pendre et puis on voit à
travers cette commission que trump
savait par son staff en l'occurrence que
est lui même par le procureur général
william barre il a réaffirmé en fait que
la requête de trump de remettre en cause
le scrutin était une folie donc trump
savait par son staff qu'il ne pouvait
pas remettre en cause ce scrutin que ça
devait être impossible et or il l'a fait
tout de même ça c'est assez assez
incroyable mais même mike pence à dieu
était pratiquement qui filtre est
tellement les gens à l'intérieur avait
peur avait compris que c'était presque
sa vie qui était qu'ils étaient en
danger dont il ya un extrême violence et
et et donald trump comme vous le dites a
beaucoup de chance peut-être d'être élu
est toute la question et cette
commission qui se pose c'est est-ce que
quelques républicains vont écouter et
regarder en tout cas l'envié est là mais
elle est une république et
voilà on verra elle compte entendait
justement inquiets mais qu est-ce qu on
dirait cette émission est ce que les
républicains vont enfin entendre un peu
de cette commission et donc évoluer
bouger dans leurs votes c'est ça le seul
enjeu en fait pas si le démocrate sont
sont convaincus elle est drôle c'est
arrivé à des sortir un peu quelques
républicains du contraintes aux
manifestants ce n'est pas dans leur
intérêt surtout pas à quelques mois des
élections à mi mandat sûrement pas mais
le désavouer donald trump est de dire
que ce que dit cette commission est vrai
alors qu'effectivement elle se repose
tout ce qu'elle dit repose sur des
images sur des éléments des témoignages
willy absolument un une volonté de bonne
partie des élus républicains d'ignorer
cela pour leurs intérêts à court terme
parce que vouloir que trump reviennent
c'est pour leurs intérêts directs tout
de même moi je suis assez admiratif des
institutions américaines je crois qu'il
faut le redire on a toujours des états
unis l'image de ce pays extrêmement
violent il ya eu une attaque récente
dans l'école etc donc on parle toujours
des états unis au fond quelque part le
pays du chaos et bien au milieu de ce
chaos il ya des institutions qui
fonctionnent c'est quand même ce qu'ils
font là les élus liste chesnais qui
n'est autre que la fille de l'ancien
secrétaire d'état à la défense de george
bush qui avait très mauvaise presse en
europe a très vite juste titre à propos
de l'irak donc je crois qu'il faut
saluer le système américain lorsqu'il
fonctionne et quand même est-ce qu'il
n'ya pas un espace pour que main à un
moment donné une partie des américains
se rendent compte que le système la
solidité du système vaut mieux que de
ramener donald trump à la présidence je
ne sais pas s'il ya une porsche entre
gens raisonnables aux états unis mais
espérons-le ans plus tard sa des
républiques et à hélices chine et qui
tient à la constitution américaine et
puis il ya tous les autres aujourd'hui à
l'espagne elle est saine seuls les
belges se sent quand même extrêmement
difficiles durant la campagne qui en
fait un lieu déjà maintenant la campagne
pour les midterms extrêmement difficile
pour les candidats amérique et candidat
républicain pardon de nier les évidences
parce que ces images elles parlent même
si fox news refuse de les diffuser les
autres les diffusent et elle parle
d'elle-même et les démocrates ne vont
pas se priver de les diffuser de les
rediffuser au moment de la campagne ou
alors les démocraties s'adresse aux
démocrates c'est ça le problème s'éclate
amérique est tellement clivé chacun a
ses chaînes presque et d'ailleurs les
républicains ont dit le jour où nous on
arrive au pouvoir si on arrive enfin
c'est ce qu'ils pensent qu'ils gagneront
les mi-temps ils sont pas vraies
cette commission pour nous sera nulle et
nana devenu on la jette rang panier
fighter déjà ils disent on va jeter au
panier ce que ce que l'amérique produit
de mieux parce qu'effectivement vous
avez raison cette commission c'est ce
que l'amérique produit de mieux ce
regard que sont capables de porter les
américains leurs députés sur leurs
erreurs bon nombre de pays ne le font
pas en malheureusement l'évidence
parfois aux etats unis quand vous voyez
que parce qu'il ya pas eu qu'une seule
tuerie
déjà en plein plein et quand vous voyez
que malgré tout tous que tout ce que les
républicains tous que la majorité des
américains réclament c'est que les gens
soient encore plus armé pour justement
lorsqu'il ya des amendements le deuxième
amendement de la constitution
actuellement sacrés sacré voilà je suis
pas sûr que l'évidence l'évidence trump
saute finalement les ailleurs il ya
quand même une vraie faute de la part
cette policière qui témoigne bien libre
à cette policière je crois de la police
du congrès américain puisque c'est une
police à part bien évidemment elles
témoignent de ce qui s'est passé mais il
y a eu aussi des fautes dans la halle
dans la défense du capitole qui on est
et qui peut être aurait pu empêcher d'en
arriver là j'imagine que ça fait partie
des autres sujets qui sont prises en
compte par cette commission on aurait dû
leur prêter notre gaz lacrymogène qui
fait des merveilles soi-disant en tout
cas trump ne sera pas inquiété 6
si j'en crois parce qu'en fait il ya une
enquête pénale en parallèle mais alors
est-ce qu effectivement les tribunaux
américains vont utiliser peut-être des
éléments de cette enquête pour pouvoir
l'attaquer au pénal c'est quand même une
question oui je pense que pour l'instant
rien lui arrive alors il est une bonne
étoile le moins qu'on puisse dire
mais je pense que ces deux enquêtes sont
très embêtante pour lui les deux
enquêtes pénales finalement presque plus
gênante que ce qui se passe là avec la
commune agents mois et pourquoi parce
que là c'est dans un autre ressort et là
ça touche au porte monnaie là c'est le
porte-monnaie et l'argent c'est quelque
chose de très important aux états unis
et donc il ya les juges c'est pas les
mêmes courses et pas les mêmes jeux
c'est pas les mêmes palata cotterêts
allons faire c'est
tout à fait mais je crois que
effectivement parce que d'abord la
justice aux états unis et le poids de
l'institution judiciaire est quand même
extrêmement fort c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que donald trump a tout fait pour la
tordre et pour essayer d'en d'en
modifier la composition lorsqu'il était
président moi je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
si serein que ça aujourd'hui dans la
halle trump il y à une projection on
imagine qu'il va faire un retour
glorieux glorieux pour son camp d'ici
deux ans c'est quand même extrêmement
difficile pour lui encore une fois parce
que ses adversaires avant lui jeter tous
à la figure et bien sûr il ya pour
l'instant on n'a pas entendu de joe
biden la grande question c'est de savoir
si joe biden peut apparaître comme une
statue comme un quelqu'un qui rassemble
en ce moment dans les sondages et amiens
il à dire on est d'accord il est lé plus
tôt ensuite joe biden sans problème
alexandra schwartzbrod en plus ce les a
mais acker manifestement c'est
l'inflation qui les intéressent beaucoup
plus même que les résultats de cette
enquête
moi je moi je suis très inquiète je te
dire pour pour la suite et et donald
trump c'est un peu comme benyamin
nétanyahou c'est le nombre de fois où on
a dit c'est la fin il va tomber il a
déjà trop d'affaires sur le dos et puis
finalement chaque fois ils arrivaient à
s'en sortir
donald trump malheureusement il est très
fort quelque part il arrive à retourner
les situations donc la moelle et
républicaine bien l'utiliser ils ont
besoin est mort dix et il a lâché quand
ils ont besoin de le lâcher mais ce pont
dirais qu'il est une espèce d'emprise
sur les républicains et kiki duc est due
à différents facteurs
étaient popularité des questions
d'intérêts personnels pour les uns pour
les autres et ils n'arrivent pas se
défaire de cette emprise les
républicains et même pour les lélés
beaucoup d'américains le vois comme une
espèce de héros qui arrive à dire fuck
aux institutions aux qui arrive à dire
fuck à poutine a enfin abouti nous
maintenons mais ne voudront pas poutine
au contraire mais enfin qui a tout les à
la plupart des leaders du monde et ça
ils aiment bien et ça ils aiment bien et
ça il le retrouve pas chez joe biden
cette espèce de cette espèce de culot et
de et de enfonce on fonce d'abord on
réfléchit après donc moi je suis je suis
plutôt inquiètes pour pour la suite mais
la prod quinzaine avec tout ce qui
arrive en ce moment sur un plan
économique qui se ramasse la hausse des
prix de l'essence l'inflation à 9% la
catastrophe
cac
bien partons donc aux états unis
allons-y meneur au dessinateur avec les
cinés même pour commencer avec ceux des
démocrates des républicains les
dessinateurs et bien figurez vous qu'il
y en a des deux côtés et que les dessins
sont en train de se radicaliser c'est un
truc assez fade j'en profite pour faire
un aparté c'est à dire qu'on assiste
maintenant à une chose qu'on connaît
très peu en europe ou en gros tous les
dessinateurs sur la base des droits
humains dignité compagnie aux états unis
vous avez vraiment maintenant des
dessinateurs républicain qui fonderont
de dessin à charge sur les démocrates
systématiquement et vice versa
donc c'est assez fascinant hobson les
chaînes effectivement deviennent soient
démocrates ou républicaines oui mais du
côté des dessinateurs de présentons nous
apprend qu'une de nos principales armes
c'est l'esprit critique et d'être
capable de se moquer de notre propre
camp si on en a un c'est quand même
assez stupéfiante d'assister à ça c'est
pas le cas de tous mais on commence à
voir un petit phénomène alors je jouais
et je ne peux pas vous dit en tout cas
du lp est ce dessin n'est elle pas en
faveur de donald trump puisqu'il numbi
nous emmène dans une chambre d'hôpital
où se trouve donc le sam symbole vous
l'avez compris des états unis et
l'infirmière ou le médecin la médecin
qui lui dit ce n'est pas un coup vie de
long que vous avez c'est bien pire et on
voit à l'écran
et le long terme langton c'est
évidemment donald trump et restons sur
ce personnage de trump avec ce dessin
deux patronnes bulgare
ce dessin de rodriguez dessinateur
mexicain très talenteux de graphiquement
il reprend vous l'aurez reconnue pour
les cinéphiles l'image du joker dans la
semaine dernière version du film de l'an
dernier avec joaquin phoenix personnage
à la fois terrifiant et fascinant et qui
dont je rappelle que le principal moteur
et le chaos suis pas si ce que rodriguez
voulais vous annoncer avec ce capital en
flammes derrière je trouve que
graphiquement ce dessin est une
merveille même s'il fait un peu froid
dans le dos et un autre dessin très
puissant graphiquement de au secours qui
peut être et la façon dont ils imaginent
vie que donald trump devrait rester dans
l'histoire c'est à dire dans les
poubelles de l'histoire je trouve ce
descendant très amusant d'abord parce
que comme toujours avec au secours on ne
sait pas bien si on est dans le dessin
dans la photo retouchée dans les espèces
de dar graphique totale on a ce capital
qui penche un petit peu qui va sans
doute se casser la gueule est ce que je
trouve fascinant c'est que personne ne
s'est posé la question mais qui est donc
sur ce dessin on sait tous que c'est
donald trump ce qui est quand même un
tour de force un graphique 1 comme vous
dites
mais on va partir au royaume uni parce
que là aussi il se passe des choses avec
boris johnson trois jours après avoir
survécu à un vote de défiance et le vote
des défenses étaient il ya trois jours
mené par son propre camp boris johnson a
tenté de se relancer en promettant à des
mesures pour faire face à la hausse du
coût de la vie il reste à son poste donc
finalement boris johnson mais le premier
ministre a connu une fronde cent
quarante et une voix contre lui au sein
de son propre camp dont ce n'est pas la
majorité mais alors est-ce le début de
la fin et il a faibli définitivement
alexandra a définitivement je suis là
c'est pareil hein je le mets un peu dans
le même sac que les deux que donald
trump et benyamin nétanyahou c'est ce
genre d'homme qui ont un talent
particulier pour rebondir quoi qu'il
arrive donc là on attendait avec
impatience de voir si ce coup ci serait
le bon ça ne l'a pas été cela dit cela
dit il s'est passé quand même quelque
chose cela en ce début de semaine c'est
que d'un coup
et la confiance a été perdu dire que
tout à coup boris johnson n'inspire plus
autant confiance à la fois à son propre
parti et à une partie des britanniques
là ça commence à s'effriter s'est pas
encore massif donc il va tenir encore un
petit peu mais on a l'impression quand
même qu'il ya un début début de défiance
qui s'est installée vous êtes d'accord
patricia du cac le très conservateur
telegraph a titré une fausse victoire
tout de même bah oui parce que d'abord
on se souvienne l'expérience malheureuse
de theresa may qui après avoir eu le
soutien de son parti a dû démissionner
quelques mois plus tard et ça paraît
quand même scénario est le même scénario
parce que même s'il a aujourd'hui la
majorité au sein de son parti et donc
ils pensent pouvoir gouverner mais des
têtes députés peuvent progressivement
lui retirer lors des votes à l'assemblée
leur confiance et donc l'empêcher
finalement de gouverner mais ça je pense
qu'ils le feront une fois qu'ils auront
trouvé un remplaçant ce qu'ils n'ont pas
et une fois qu'ils verront peut-être
aussi les résultats des deux prochaines
élections du mois du mois de juin là ça
peut continuer mais s'ils veulent
l'empêcher de gouverner ils ont les
moyens et un premier ministre qui peut
plus gouverner si la chambre ne vote
plus ces propositions de loi il doit
démissionner et il y une dernière chose
que je dis il ya cette fameuse
commission la dernière qui va rendre son
verdict prochainement à la rentrée je
crois si je ne me trompe pas et s'il est
reconnu qu'il a menti à la chambre et
bien ne pourra plus pénétrer dans la
chambre et alors là ça serait la
sanction fatal alors le mensonge oui
alors moi je voudrais pas jouer à
l'optimiste autour de ce bateau mais moi
je consomme c'est fini pour boris
johnson a cédé pense que je pense que
c'est presque fini et l'optimiste
faisait presque infini parce que oui
optimisme pour ses partenaires parce que
je crois que tout le monde en a
ras-le-bol de bruce nous sommes surtout
les anglais est ce que nous en oublions
pas non plus qu il trahi les engagements
pris par son pays vis-à-vis l'union
européenne ont produit devrait exister
du protocole n'a rien demandé je pense
que c'est fini pour une raison simple
c'est que un remplaçant va finir par
apparaître pour l'instant il y en avait
été le chancelier
richy sounac et comme par hasard il se
retrouve pris dans un scandale parce que
sa femme indienne d'une très riche
famille on découvre qu'elle ne paie pas
d'impôts royaume uni jeudi comme par
hasard parce qu'il ya eu des fuites dans
la presse qui en tient un double double
elle venir ces fuites donc je crois que
boris johnson est vraiment le dos au mur
l'opinion publique britannique une
grande partie en a marre de ce type
qu'elle ne juge pas crédible par contre
ils gardent quand même je dirais une
munition le le jeu de mot est mal trouvé
mais c'est la guerre en ukraine parce
que là sur ce sujet là il peut jouer
giresse il continue de jouer sur la
scène diplomatique
mais très franchement je pense que ses
jours à la tête du royaume uni sont que
sont tout de même compter vous avez tous
vu quand il a monté les marches pour le
jubilé de la reine elle a été tuée mais
c'est quand même une scène totalement
accablante si vous êtes d'accord
alexandre alexandrov bronze pas vraiment
voilà je pense que il va finir par
tomber à plus ou moins brève échéance
malheureusement oui là il ya pas mal de
il est fort risqué ne sonne on peut
c'est quelqu'un de c'est quelqu'un qui a
fait un mal fou à l'union européenne à
son pays qui n'a pas arrêter de mentir
en fait c'est son image de bouffon il
s'est construit il s'est construit sur
une image de bouffon et ça peut ça finit
par se retourner contre lui ce que vous
savez il arrivait quand il était maire
de londres avec ses cheveux en l'air
parlons en exil ont débraillé et c est
là ça finit par se retourner contre lui
c'est avec le parti des lacets le
bouffon on en a assez et le parti gates
est plus possible a vu ce que les gens
ont vécu on subit c'est plus possible
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que ça
ressemble plus au commencement de la fin
la grande différence mais ne tient pas
le parti oui il a montreuil un ne tient
pas le maintien partiel par titre est
déchiré en fait en mission des tories
sont pas d'accord et je suis d'accord à
doter il est d'autant plus des radios
mériterait qu'ils utilisent des des
subventions et utilisé des subventions
pour aider les britanniques c'est
complètement à l'opposé de la politique
économique des tories donc ils utilisent
des choses qui vont à l'encontre de tout
ce que les tories se défend trois points
économiques les dessinateurs de minutes
et noise on va faire ça très rapidement
dessinateur va commencer par un petit
symbole graphique qu'on utilise souvent
quand il ya quelque chose de surprenant
et de terrifiant c'est un des cinq nous
propose ramsès dessinateur cubain quel
est le résultat du vote de défiance
bombay le diable qui sort de la boîte
tout simplement avec son ressort c'est
rigolo surtout j'aime bien la tête qu'il
a fait à johnson presque enfantin et on
le reconnaît immédiatement c'est assez
marrant enchaînons rapidement avec ce
dessin d'hermann dessinateur suisse
publiée cette semaine en une du monde je
reste dit boris johnson à la reine
parfait plus il vous voit plus il même
évidemment dessin très simple mais très
drôle comme souvent avec herman et enfin
des sa balise oublier la haine
exactement vous allez le voir on y vient
vous lisez dans mes pensées dessin de
heng de singapour qui nous montre la
scène du jubilé le baissant s'appelle
the crown and the cloud vous prie de
noter avec cette reine et ce boris
johnson en petit gamin bas l'elysée qui
sort de sa fête d'anniversaire je trouve
ça hilarant hilarant c'est indécent de
zinc et dessinateur de singapour pour le
lien là où pousse à vous merci beaucoup
cac d'avoir été avec no mercy patricia
allemonière merci richard wehrli merci
alexandre à ashford brode merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver la semaine dans le monde en
podcast depuis bien sûr sur le site
internet
www.francebillet.com et les réseaux
sociaux twitter facebook reste avec nous
et bon week-end à tous
[Musique]